all right let's uh let's stick with the
phones we'll go to our next caller from
the 2:09 area code 209 caller please
tell us your name where you're calling
from and what's on your mind today
right okay they're shy 209 maybe has
fallen asleep I've had people email
saying they actually they were laying
down while on hold and they fell asleep
comic the music is quite calming yeah
okay let's instead then try our caller
from the three one six area code caller
from three one six tell us who you are
and what's on your mind today I booked
you David Peck good thank you what can
we answer for you today is that it Wow
are you still with us caller hmm okay
well that's that was it we really got
through that one pretty quick so that's
good all right next and possibly last
caller today from the eight one eight
area code what is your name and where
you're calling from and what can we do
for you today what's going on today Pat
I don't know no no it's very very
strange what's going on we're going to
try one more attempt here let's go to
our caller who has been holding on for a
while from the nine five two area code
caller you're our last caller today
please tell us what's on your mind today
Sal addiction Vivek my name is Tariq I'm
calling from grocery on Minnesota
awesome what's on your mind
now I have two questions for you first
question is what's your take on up our
siege and the second question is what do
you think is the most efficient the
presidential system of that past
apartment above Arsenal's system